well McCain is increasingly trying to
run as a Republican after having been a
maverick virtue almost an independent
for for the past eight years and
therefore he's saying a lot of things
which I think are wrong and dangerous
he's defending tax cuts that he voted
against he needs if he's to win the
nomination and if he is to run as a
Republican candidate he needs to
convince the base the Republican base
that he is one of them having not been
one of them for some for some period of
time and so he's saying a lot of things
which I hope he doesn't believe he's
defending tax cuts that he voted against
he is no longer as passionately against
torture as he has as he has been in the
past he he's defending a policy on an
anti welfare politics which I I also
hope he doesn't believe but all of those
would be dangerous because they are the
continuation of of a Republican program
that has brought the country into a
state of radical unfairness and
inequality